you i was watching she's been checked
dog i was watching the other day on uh
youtube when sasso came on firing the
kid and was redoing montel jordan
[Applause]
he's just he's one of the funniest have
you talked to him
yeah i talked to him periodically but
he's all heidi heidi because of kobe
kobe oh yeah
the guy big guy big guy so i think he's
a little worried about it all big guys
are yeah
like but all my big friends are like he
won't hang with me because i travel
you know and he's like nah you're on the
road so we're not getting him on the
show for quite some time
he's got to get vaccinated but he's uh
he's been a lot like he's some people
are
so funny naturally like they're just so
impossibly talented
i've said that to him before i go i
think you're the greatest
impressionist i've ever i've ever seen
in my life and how how did this show do
i don't see it it got cancelled yeah oh
the 108 nbc well if you want to play
that game if you want to be on
mainstream tv yeah you pilots yeah don't
get picked up
or how about i think kevin james taking
all his jobs you know well kevin james
is something else but even that
even that's hard well he's on netflix
now yeah
but i mean how many people are watching
it's always i don't know tv has just
changed so much
this whole business has changed
drastically if you're going to put all
your eggs
in a netflix show now hold on
so so new media podcasting stand up
we're all very lucky because if you're
doing a
netflix show you're gonna do eight
episodes ten episodes and a lot of times
that contract keeps you from doing you
can't do anything
else so that so you shot so how long
does it take to do ten episodes
i'm gonna i'll give it i'll give it
three months give it yeah maybe okay
i'll give it
three months so now you got now you got
nine more months
to eat right you have to figure it out
what are you going to do you have a
podcast
you can't pay your mortgage on that i'm
not paying you that much
i'm saying in l.a yeah james can yeah if
you're kevin james yeah but if you're
just
a person on there no if you're if you're
fourth lead yeah
supportive yeah you need something more
by the way speaking of acting
yeah you saw oh you saw it you saw that
oh yeah yeah yeah
what's that it was good took my words i
liked it what was it yeah
oh yeah yeah wait so was it a commercial
for xbox or otterbox because i saw both
well here's the thing uh it was a collab
okay but
but it was more xbox i have three more
is it on tv
uh i reposted it is it on youtube or no
it's on you
we put on youtube it's on youtube have
you posted to your social media
yeah yeah i'm getting a lot of positive
reviews uh we have uh i'm shooting
another one in march
look at that right there now we can
critique going on uh
i was much smaller back then look at
that posture
i like it look at that look at that
look at the walk look at that look yeah
the focus
now do you have any speaking lines oh
okay we'll get to that
yeah look at that look at the handle
okay
this is the girl i was telling you about
how can we get you to stare at your
phone more
you play xbox on your video on your
phone now that's so dope
oh damn calm down man yeah now here this
is my line watch okay where do you talk
[Music]
now man where where's your lines at yeah
look what look what brian come
i'm glad you took my acting workshop i
take credit for this commercial now
why well because because because what i
just feel like
i did i'm sorry did i talk when he spoke
did i miss the
what were your lines my line was game
connected
did i was that in there it was think
about hollywood think about hollywood
it's not about the lines about the
intention thank you
thank you b you saw you saw my face you
saw them
now i don't want to say anybody could do
that but wow three more they chose me
you smiled and smiled
i have a great time i believed you no
they chose you for sure i mean your
chosen one i had an acting teacher i was
doing a scene one time in acting class
from a bunch of people i didn't know and
i'm doing this heavy
trying to [ __ ] and i just hear the
teacher go i don't believe you
[Laughter]
i believe you i believe you on the third
dragon have you ever taken uh acting
classes yeah i did for like three years
how'd it go
i liked it i i i think acting classes
are dope i hated mine you hated him yeah
didn't like him mr pettigrew he was so
hard on me
once you go somewhere else there's
thousands well because he said if you
quit now
you're gonna quit in life and that stuck
with me yeah but you could just go to
another acting coach you're not
necessarily
not necessarily just leaving he just
wasn't the teacher's supposed to be hard
on you sometimes
yeah because you get caught in your
little tricks he taught me how to cry on
the spot that's the guy who like he was
like i want to see better
but the other thing if you're an acting
coach think how much [ __ ] riff raff
you deal with in your class
oh nobody oh so much most people aren't
going to make it this girl is from
nebraska she's homecoming queen teaching
me the next
[ __ ] you know big thing but they told
me the acting teachers that never made
it though
if you really look at it but there are
some great teachers who
those who can't coach yeah some of them
are amazing though like someone a lot of
times they're trying to get you out of
your own way
what do you know jeffrey oh [ __ ] he had
a
acting coach who's like award-winning he
was oh jeffy were you
was your coach yeah for years oh wow can
you can you get him with me one of the
greatest
he's one of the greatest he does he's
one of the great actors
i mean ever i put him up against
and he was one of the greatest teachers
that [ __ ] was psychic
that dude would look back and go like
this he would go he'd go
what's going on and you'd be like you
want the good news you want the bad news
and there's oh good news first good good
good news is you got one foot out in one
foot in bad news
you got one foot out right what happened
think about quitting now
people start crying
my favorite is this guy's doing scene
and he goes
after the scene we'd all be waiting to
see what he's going to say i need to go
what's going on with your right leg you
gotta go what
he goes your right leg what's going on
so you're so protected that leg and
that's i just see you kind of your whole
body's
leaning in that direction guy goes
nothing i don't know
nothing nothing's going on with your
right leg guy goes i mean
you don't see that walk for a second
walk i'd be like
and go yeah see and he goes well i mean
yeah i mean
nothing ever happened he goes i mean i
was in the crocs and i broke my femur in
half yeah so i had well it's
the [ __ ] could pick up on that
kind of stuff bees it just ain't just
you dude
like his antenna a student of human
behavior yeah
and then he would sometimes show you how
to do something
and and like like you'd do a scene and
you'd work on it and or
my favorite this you go watch this you
go how long do you work on the scene
so tell me like tell me tell me 12 hours
hold on
three hours maybe and i'm being generous
so what's going on you don't want to you
want to do this i've seen it all man
you can leave you've seen it all yeah
but he's still he's still not doing it
is he
no he stopped teaching 2002 yeah he's
just blown up
yeah i think he's what's funny i was
talking to chapelle about this is
agents trying to adapt to you know now
there's podcasts and stand up yeah
youtube you can there's all these
different digital apps and they're
trying to keep up
and then they throw you tv ideas and
you're like let's go through this if i
get that tv show
so i'm shooting you say monday through
friday well you know i have a podcast
monday through thursdays the only day
well that's now i do the i have no every
day i podcast
so if you if i if you have to take that
away then
how much is the conversation yeah but
and i will just think about the long
play
i own these podcasts so you want me to
do this tv show and shut down all this
for
for how long and you'll work for 16
hours a day please yeah
yeah and what i mean by that is you'll
be in makeup waiting but it's it's funny
to watch
it's funny to watch them juggle what do
you mean agents
yeah just because they it's just i'm
like how much to pay you know i make
that in a day doing this like
yeah i know but that's podcast i'm like
i'm sorry so is that less
than this tv network mm-hmm you're
getting it
if you want people if you want fame have
a
successful podcast it's gonna people are
going to know you a lot more
oh 100 but also think about it like
when's the like how much do you know
about leonardo dicaprio
i don't know i don't know anything you
ever heard him on long form podcast how
much you know about joe rogan or brian
cowan or yeah tim
dillon or chris delete andrew was andrew
schultz doing a shitload of tv before
this no he made it no he was he was on
twitter
but he people know him from 100 percent
from his just being
so amazing on social media and being
like we go
and that's adapting in 2021 these
celebrities now who are untouchable and
there's there's a few at the pinnacle
but outside that no one gives a [ __ ]
about the rest of them yeah there's like
this elite like
name name the last in the past three
years and i'll wait this is the truth
who yeah who who were the uh give me a
couple names of
of actual oscar winners it used to be
they were household names
who won an oscar last year well that's
just just really uh supporting yeah
that brad pitt we know because we've
known him yeah it's brad
yeah we don't actors are no longer what
they were because it's so atomized yeah
they just
there's people you got you're competing
with youtube podcasts
stand up so many everything so so an
actor no longer can capture
you know the imagine the collective
imagination how many people have seen
the movie how many
moonlight won an oscar okay there's a
movie name one actor from it
uh trevonte rose i was in the film with
him marshay ali
um well it's an all black cast yes in
black guys yeah but yeah
yeah most people would not know that
yeah not enough it's just it's just what
it's just the narratives changed the
media has changed meanwhile
i do love the world of acting i think
it's such an amazing like
thing like just to see someone portray
something and
like one of my favorite actors yeah one
of my favorite actors is val kilmer i
love val kilmer
you know i think he's [ __ ] great he's
great and uh
you know just to watch him like portray
something like
and you no longer see val kilmer i think
i don't know i just think it's badass
right now he's your favorite actor huh
right now one of one of my favorites
he hasn't worked in a long time no he
has a yeah
you know oh when they first like yeah
that i think i was doing
1992. he's probably 96
yeah really yeah i think he's literally
95. 95.
yeah wow still holds up sure does
we had to do a monologue uh great movie
in that scene yeah you had to do that
you had to do that yeah you see that
yeah in the monologue
they initially sit down together that's
the shooting scene
or that yes celebrities all different
now isn't it because you got
like i was at zoo gym uh the owner
introduced me to this tick tocker
i think much of it and then uh
he just popped up on my youtube feed and
he has like i don't know
like a hundred million followers you
know his name
no i don't clue 100 million
talkers are the modern superstars now
he's so rich
talkers yeah tick tockers yeah they're
like they're talking to my daughter
she's 12 and she's just like everyone's
obsessed yeah but it's all
niche right like that guy not even
really that big of a niche
these kids have like 30 million
followers it's still niche though
because that kid could get coffee no one
knows who he is like leonardo dicaprio
can't the age of the big star is not
there
also 100 million followers that last how
long's the last time
how much how much talent do they
actually really have and a hundred
million followers on instagram doesn't
mean that a hundred million people in
the world can equate yeah yeah like yeah
yeah to the point that social media
isn't real they say one in ten people
are on social media when walk down the
street
so if that kid gets coffee they don't
know who he is yeah
but also also your you did it in
30-second bursts
there's it's a little bit different of a
skill set i think you know it's not that
they're not talented it's just
you got to sustain a different your
audience is 12 year olds too
tick tock is a young audience that's
very fickle they'll just go on to the
next thing
yeah let's go some current events how
about that when i get off stage at the
lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son